meanwhile another judge fighting tears
last night Mel B Mel definitely she's
very emotional right now and also you
know she had just lost her dad and she's
going through a lot of stuff right now
and it's not easy you know being in the
public eye I was actually teared up a
little bit I don't know who songs or you
know stories it hits home you know so
I'm sure to hit home from out
Mel's recent admission that she is at a
crisis point and will seek treatment for
PTSD at a UK rehab facility after a GT
rafts made headlines but her fellow
judges tell us she hasn't let it affect
her work Mel the truth you know what I
promise you she comes to the show leaves
everything behind focuses on the
contestant that is a true professional
she is a very strong wonderful lady
whatever she needs from me I would hope
that she would reach out and I'll reach
out to her recognize my own song where
you killed it yes you
it's not easy but you know for me I'm
her friend I've been her friend for a
very long time and I'm always gonna be
there for her and help her and whatever
it is she needs help in Mel's
seven-year-old daughter Madison
supported her on the AG T red carpet
last night and also showing her support
ellen guest host lea michele and mel
shared some Spice Girls news with her
and the episode that aired today we are
definitely gonna reunite that's amazing
I was posh spice for Halloween when
you're doing with me I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]